ever since his debut in the Phantom
Menace Darth Baal has become one of Star
Wars most iconic villains but his tale
stretches far beyond that one movie from
his sinister origins to his final tool
this is the story of Darth Maul the
child who would eventually become Darth
Maul was born on the planet daffa Mir a
world controlled by a matriarchal order
of Darkseid force users known as the
Nightsisters Baal grew up in a tribe
ruled by the ferocious mother Talzin
Talzin planned for her three sons to
become Knight brothers the all-male
warriors who protect and serve the
Nightsisters but all that changed on the
day that Darth Sidious came to Dathomir
as part of his plan for galactic
domination Sidious wish to learn more of
the dark side from the Nightsisters
after working with mother Talzin for a
time Sidious was impressed by her
abilities and offered to take her on as
his new apprentice but he never did
instead Sidious kidnapped one of Towson
sons and vanished from Dathomir
he not only sensed great potential in
the boy but also wanted an apprentice
that he could control completely
whatever this child's birth name was
it's now lost to history as Sidious
renamed him Maul Sidious his
brainwashing of Darth Maul was
successful and he grew up to be a
formidable Sith Warrior due to his
tremendous skill Maul was also impatient
for the time when he would finally get
the chance to fight a Jedi but because
Sidious didn't want to reveal the Sith
orders reemergence until the last
possible moment he forbade Maul from
doing so
despite this Maul soon learns of a jedi
padawan named Eldrick uydess who has
been captured by a criminal cartel Baal
decides to ignore his masters orders to
remain hidden and travels to the auction
where Titus is being sold as a slave
after a series of misadventures Maul
manages to rescue Titus from captivity
only to then challenged her to a duel in
the end even though Kai despites
valiantly Maul defeats and kills her
after Darth Maul returns to his master
he suspects that Sidious will be upset
with him for his disobedience but
Sidious congratulate him telling him
that the Sith were born in defiance and
that Maul has embraced the very nature
of their order Darth Sidious asks his
apprentice if his bloodlust has been
sated by this and maul tells him that it
has not Sidious replies good after years
of planning Darth Sidious finally sets
in motion his plan for galactic
domination
unfortunately Queen Amidala of Naboo and
two troublesome Jedi began mucking up
Sidious is carefully laid plans
Sidious dispatches Maul to track them
down and
a brief encounter on Tatooine they
finally come to blows in the Royal
Palace on Naboo
since Maul is outnumbered he decides to
separate his two foes naki and obi-wan
off a ledge so that he can fight qui-gon
uninterrupted by the time obi-wan
manages to reunite with them Darth Maul
has stabbed qui-gon through the chest
killing him
filled with rage obi-wan fights more
fiercely than ever and through some
tricky force assisted acrobatics manages
to chop Maul in half and send him
tumbling down a seemingly bottomless
shaft kept alive by the sheer force of
his hatred for Kenobi maul survives his
defeat on the boo crawls through the
underbelly of the palace and finally
makes his escape balls upper half ends
up getting shipped off with the trash to
lotho-minor
a planet that is covered in an endless
junkyard there he manages to replace his
lower body with some scavenged robotic
legs but he's forced to live in dire
circumstances with little food or water
and no way off the planet years later
back on top Emir a knight brother named
Savage Opress learns from his mother
Talzin that he has a long-lost brother
who was taken from them by Darth Sidious
with the help of towels and sports
sensitivity Cevallos ends up tracking
down wall but the man he finds is so
consumed with rage and so damaged by
isolation that is practically an animal
were still vast swaths of his memory are
totally missing servoz decides to bring
him back to Dathomir once their mother
Talzin uses her mysterious darkside
magic to begin restoring mauls
fragmented mind finally reunited for the
first time in decades Sabah's Opress and
Darth Maul decide to join forces and
travel the galaxy together and search a
power and revenge along the way Maul
starts referring to savage as his
apprentice teaching him the ways of the
dark side they also start recruiting
allies such as the criminal organization
Black Sun the radical Mandalorian
revolutionary group Death Watch and the
forces of Jabba the Hutt wall and semaj
decide to name their new criminal
network the shadow collective as well as
building the shadow collective he gets a
few opportunities to cross lightsabers
with obi-wan Kenobi
the first occurs when Maul sets a trap
for the Jedi Master on the planet
raydonia but Kenobi manages to escape
before Maul can land a killing blow
later Kenobi tracks Maul and Savage to
the planet floor room but this time it's
Maul who flees after Kenobi cuts off one
of savages actual arms during this time
the shadow collective accomplishes a
great deal they even managed to organize
a coup on the planet Mandalore
allowing the collective to seize control
of the planets government during this
time on Mandalore
mall also manages to obtain a new weapon
an ancient lightsaber with a black blade
known as the dark saber soon after
taking control of Mandalore mall lures
obi-wan Kenobi into a trap and captures
him although he fails to hold his sworn
enemy for long he does strike down and
kill satine kryze Kenobi's close friend
and romantic interest molls time is the
ruler of Mandalore short-lived soon
after he takes over the planet malls
doorway is once again darkened by his
old master Darth Sidious Sidious had
learned a mall survival from obi-wan
Kenobi and had now come to put down his
former apprentice once and for all
at first Maul tries to convince his old
master that he conquered Mandalore as a
gift with the hope of becoming Sidious
as apprentice once more but the Sith
Lord quickly sees through walls lies
fallen Savage Opress then fights Sidious
together but the two are separated and
oprah's proves no match for Sidious by
himself he is quickly struck down by the
Sith Lord Maul then returns to the fight
but fails the must of the rage he needs
to defeat Sidious instead all he feels
is grief as a result small is distracted
and unfocused and Darth Sidious is able
to easily overpower him and take him
captive soon after Maul finds himself in
prison face to face with Sidious new
apprentice Count Dooku Dooku subject
small to torture attempting to extract
information about the shadow collective
of course small doesn't offer up much
shortly thereafter shadow collective
forces are able to rescue Maul from
prison unfortunately by this point in
time the collective's days are numbered
being an enemy to both the Jedi and the
Sith has really left Maul stuck between
a rock and a hard place and he finds his
allies abandoning him left and right
Maul does achieve one brief victory when
his forces capture Count Dooku and hold
him prisoner
however despite mauls attempts to
contact Sidious and use his new hostage
as leverage his old master claims he has
no use for either of them anymore
he tells Maul he is free to kill Dooku
undeterred Maul then pivot strategies he
and mother Talzin attempt to convince
Dooku into forming an alliance with him
against Sidious but Dooku refuses
stating that he just doesn't believe in
alliance against Darth Sidious could
ever succeed Maul and Duke who are then
interrupted by an attack on their supply
outpost
it seems that a group of Republic
soldiers led by obi-wan Kenobi and mace
Windu have found them given this new
development
Dooku vanes an alliance with Maul and
the two Sith Lords are able to fight
their way through the Jedi and escape
wall then returns with Dooku to his
homeworld of
Damir in order to lay low and seek the
counsel of his mother Wally is there
however Dathomir is attacked by darth
sidious forces led by darth sidious and
general grievous Baal manages to rally
his shadow collective forces to fight
back against the invasion but it doesn't
make much of a difference during the
battle mother Talzin and Maul duel
Grievous Dooku and Sidious Talzin then
uses her powers to push Maul away from
the fight in an attempt to save him
moments later she is killed by Grievous
well briefly tries to charge back into
the fray but is dragged away by a shadow
collective warriors and convinced to
flee to planet eventually Maul and those
loyal to him return to Mandalore where
they remain in hiding
driven into the shadows Maul and the
shadow collective re-established ties
with the Pyke syndicate black son and a
criminal syndicate called crimson dawn
around this time Maul begins
experiencing visions of the future
specifically of the rise of Darth
Sidious the fall of Anakin Skywalker and
the coming of order 66 hoping to prevent
this by killing Skywalker Mall engineers
the siege of Mandalore is a trap for the
Jedi unfortunately from all its ahsoka
tano who leads the Republic forces on
Mandalore when they first encounter each
other Maul warns ahsoka of the imminent
rise of Darth Sidious but he's quickly
forced to flee on his second meeting
with ahsoka mall once more for warns the
rise of Darth Sidious and the Empire
ahsoka offers to work with Maul to stop
Sidious once and for all
but Baal refuses due to his belief that
the Republic and Jedi are too weak and
corrupt to be saved while then asked
ahsoka to join him to defeat Sidious
which she seriously considers until Maul
reveals that he has seen visions of
Sidious making Anakin Skywalker his new
apprentice
ahsoka accuses Maul applying lashes out
and the two come to blows after a
hard-fought duel Maul is defeated by a
souca rather than let him die however
she takes small into captivity and
prepares to return him to Khorasan for
judgment by the Jedi Council with mullin
confinement in the Clone Wars entering
its final stages ahsoka and her clone
army begin the journey back to Coruscant
where Maul is to be kept prisoner they
never make it as the Soka ship hurtles
through Lightspeed Sidious issues order
66 making the clones
turn on the Jedi and solidifying the
transformation on the Republic into the
Galactic Empire
ahsoka isn't part of the Jedi Order
anymore but she's still a hero with a
lightsaber
two of them actually making her a big
target thankfully ahsoka has Maul around
in need of a distraction to get the
clones off her tail
ahsoka frees small from his ruse
straining device and sets him loose to
cause havoc you don't understand I'm not
here to team up with you I need a
diversion and your end he more than
delivers as a so con her friend captain
racks work on their escape Maul takes
the fight to the Clone Army and
sabotages the ship's hyperdrive
generators sending the vessel careening
towards the surface of a nearby moon
with a big crash imminent maul flees to
the hangar bay where he crosses paths
with ahsoka again a brief struggle
ensues but Maul is able to commandeer a
ship and escape leaving him free to
regroup elsewhere in the galaxy and
forcing ahsoka and Rex to fend for
themselves during the reign of the
Galactic Empire maul continues to rule
the shadow collective exerting his
control over a number of criminal
organizations across the galaxy many
years after the end of the Clone Wars he
makes his final reappearance while the
young rebel Ezra Bridger is exploring
some old Citroen's on the lifeless
planet of Malachor he encounters a
stranger in a cloak the stranger
explains that he came seeking a Sith
holocron and a nearby temple but it
takes two force users working together
to open the doors to the temple so we
can't do it alone in order to help lift
the extremely heavy stones the stranger
teaches as for how to make his force
power stronger by tapping into his
emotions something that Ezra's own
mentors have forbidden under the
strangers guidance Ezra is able to
retrieve the holocron the two then
reunite with Ezra's teacher the former
Jedi Padawan Kanan Joris who immediately
recognizes the stranger as Darth Maul as
you might imagine it isn't long before
Maul betrays them and even though Maul
is defeated and forced to flee Ezra
finds that his time spent with Maul has
forever changed him giving him a taste
of the power that darkside can bring
Maul later reappears to make as Ron
offer
Maul seeks the answer to a question and
to get it he needs another Force user to
operate a pair of holocrons with him
doing so will grant the pair of shared
vision giving each participant the
answer to any question they asked Ezra
asked for the key to destroying the Sith
and Maul asked where he is they get the
same answer a desert planet with twin
suns eventually Ezra is able to put
together that Maul is seeking the
legendary Jedi obi-wan Kenobi who is
living in hiding on the planet Tatooine
Ezra travels there to warn Kenobi and
persuade him to join the rebellion but
Kenobi refuses the rebellion needs you
we need you to defeat the Empire what
you need you already have unfortunately
you seem to be letting it
Guu Walden arrives in he and Kenobi duel
one last time their battle is quick and
Kenobi wins by slicing his enemy through
the chest as Maul lays dying the two old
foes talk one last time and Kenobi
reveals that he is on Tatooine to guard
the chosen one safe and the knowledge
that he would one day be avenged and
Sidious would be destroyed maul dies in
Kenobi's arms check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and TV shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]